the 2019 general election results look
pretty definitive for the Conservatives
the Tories got the most votes won the
most seats got the biggest majority in a
generation but that doesn't tell the
full story smaller parties saw a massive
increase in supports but got very little
forests the Greens vote share when top
60 percents
the largest of any party but they still
only return one MP despite getting 3.7
million votes the Liberal Democrats only
returns and Levin seats in contrast the
SNP got 48 seats but only had 1.2
million votes less than half the Lib
Dems elsewhere worries about splitting
the remain votes that some people to
vote tactically but it didn't seem to
help in fact while 52 percent of the
total votes went to party supporting a
second referendum the pro brexit Tory
still got their huge majority these
issues have led people from all sides of
the political spectrum to call for
electoral reform so let's take a look at
some of the options what do we have at
the moment our current system is called
first-past-the-post and it's pretty
simple basically the candidates who win
the most votes get to become MPs and the
party with an overall majority of MPs
gets to form a government this
simplicity is why it's favoured by many
but others say it can be unfair causing
millions of votes to be meaningless and
leading to things like tactical voting
what are the alternatives reformers
often call for proportional
representation basically this means that
MPs would be elected based on the
percentage of votes they receive so if a
party wins 20 percent of the overall
votes they would get 20 percent of the
seats in parliament there are loads of
different types of PR one of the most
popular systems is party-list
proportional representation it's used in
80 countries around the world including
in the UK when we elect MEP s under
party list the public votes for the
party not as specific candidates
the party's draw up a list of candidates
and rank them in a preferable order the
number of candidates who get elected
from that list depends on the percentage
of votes they receive some critics say
PR is too complicated with return to
many coalition governments others points
the fact that a more proportional system
could give extremist parties an easier
route into UK politics for example in
the 2005 general election the British
National Party got as high as 17 percent
of the vote in some areas under a
proportional representation system
parties like that would have a better
chance of getting in another popular
option for change is alternative vote AV
is technically not a form of
proportional representation but some
argue it's fairer than
first-past-the-post under a V voters
ranks their favored candidates on the
ballot paper if more than half the
voters put the same candidate as their
favor they become the MP if not the
counters take a look at the second-place
votes and so on and so on until one
candidate gets a majority we actually
had a referendum of our AV back in 2011
but it was rejected by the British
public will we ever actually see
electoral reform in short probably not
realistic we only parties with the power
to change the systems and make them more
proportional of the Tories and labour
and those parties happen to benefit the
most from first-past-the-post so why
would they vote for something
differently and after the huge majority
first-past-the-post returned for Boris
Johnson it may be a while until we see
any meaningful change